i've been using the apple watch series 6
for over a week now and to be honest
it's both surprised me in a few areas
that apple didn't mention
and also disappointed me in a few ways
that i personally didn't expect
in this video i'll share my real world
experience
upgrading from the series five to the
six and help you choose if you should
upgrade
or help those of you who are trying to
decide between buying the brand new
model
or saving a hundred dollars or even more
in a series five
which by the way we have links down in
the video description below
all while still having the always-on
display that only the series 5 and the
series 6 get let's jump right in and
start with that because that's what i
was initially
most excited about apple made the
brighter always on display
a big deal and that was my biggest
complaint with the series 5
since in my opinion the screen dimmed
way too much
i wanted an apple watch that always
looked great on my wrist and had its
complications
always visible but i often still had to
raise my wrist
to get a brighter image i understand
that it dimmed that much because of
battery life which we'll talk about in
just a bit
but apple advertises two and a half
times brighter always on
but honestly it doesn't look that
different in our hands-on in boxing they
looked
almost identical even when i put a
flashlight to both watches to get them
to get brighter
in normally lit rooms there is no
difference at all
and because of that i'm still constantly
moving my wrist to see my info
instead of just glancing down the only
time i noticed an
actual difference is if i was outside
and at the same time it was a very sunny
day
which can be nice if you're sitting
around and you don't want to raise your
wrist
but typically if i'm outside i'm moving
around
anyway so it's not that big of an issue
for me the other thing i noticed is that
the series 6
seemed to be more sensitive to me moving
my hand than the 5.
it could be a software thing but at
times i found it annoying
especially when it's darker and say i'm
driving or watching a movie
and my new watch keeps lighting up
because of that i ended up using the
theater mode
way more often so if you're mostly
wanting a series 6 for that brighter
always on display
i wouldn't get it for that but there's
definitely a few other reasons to get it
and the first one that surprised me was
the battery life and the vibrations
at first i thought it was going crazy
because the silent notifications were
much more defined
than with the older watches so i
mentioned this to a dean but i was still
skeptical
until i saw i fixed its tear down where
they found a new
larger taptic engine it may not seem
like a big deal and for many it won't
be but it is a nice upgrade that i
instantly noticed
and it could be especially useful if you
use your watch as a silent alarm to wake
you up in the mornings
with that i also noticed an improvement
in battery life and it's a bigger
difference than i expected
apple keeps raiding their watches at 18
hours of battery life
but in the real world the difference can
be big when i move to the s5 for example
with it's always on display i ended the
day with 10
instead of around 35 battery life that i
had remaining with my older series 4.
this meant that if i forgot to place it
on the charger it would be dead by the
morning
and when i started using the sleep
tracker i had to remember to charge it
every night before bed with the series 6
i noticed that i was no longer getting
those charge before bed reminders and i
once again was
ending the day with about 35 to 40
battery
of course your battery life will vary
based on how you use it
but some people now end the day with 50
battery
but either way that is a significant
improvement
enough to wear your watch all night and
not worry about it dying that's
partially because of a new bigger
battery
and the other reason is the new more
powerful and more power
efficient s6 chip now the series 5
used a slightly modified s4 processor so
we're finally starting to see some
improvements from a couple years ago
as far as actual performance the only
time i noticed the difference
was animation smoothness every once in a
while like when editing watch faces so
it's really not a big deal
another noticeable difference is that 3d
touch is now gone with the series 6
physically not having the extra hardware
which could be a reason why apple was
able to add better tactics and larger
battery
i have to say that i do miss the 3d
touch since i could access a few things
a little bit faster
but with watch os 7 apple actually
disabled this function on all of the
older apple watches anyways
now let's talk about the new features
like blood oxygen sensing and the
always-on altimeter
now i don't hike very often and when i
did with the series 5 i didn't have
any issues with the older less efficient
altimeter
so i did some research and other people
that do hike
agreed that unless you hike all the time
and you want super accurate readings
this doesn't really matter as for the
blood oxygen sensing i tested it many
times and i was surprised by how many
times i had to redo the readings
now i personally don't have health
issues that require me to test my oxygen
level
but if you're somebody that does this
feature alone should push you to go for
a series 6
as long as your watch strap is tight
enough this would be a great time to
mention the new solo loop watch bands
i bought a braided one separately and i
love it
but like many people it is too loose so
i do want to point out once again to
order a smaller size than you think that
you need
of course these bands can be used with a
series 5 as well but it'll cost you a
hundred dollars for the band
instead of a 50 up charge if you're
swapping out the basic sport band so
keep that in mind
now what you can't get with the series
five are the new colors
my series six is the new red and i
ordered it with a sport band because
it's the only one that would arrive at
launch
and i really like the product red color
but unfortunately the included red sport
band
doesn't match the actual color of the
watch itself wrapping all of this
up after more than a week of use the
series 6 is the nicer watch for reasons
that i wasn't really expecting
like the new taptic engine which i
really like the better battery life
better performance
and of course the always on display if
you're outdoors
in sunny really bright conditions now
these things might be enough for you to
upgrade to the six the biggest probably
being battery life especially if you
want to use it for sleep tracking
but for me it definitely isn't now if
apple gave me the option to choose to
have the watch stay at full brightness
at all times at the cost of battery that
would do it for me
but for some reason they still don't
give us that option now if you're on the
fence trying to decide
which one of these you should buy i
would leave it up to the money
if you can get the series 5 at a
significant discount that would push me
to save the money and go for that one
but if the difference is minimal i would
definitely end up going for the series
6.
check the links down in the video
description because prices do fluctuate
and by the time you're watching this
video the series 6 could actually be on
sale as well
and at that point definitely get it for
those of you that did buy a series six
or you upgraded to one
let me know what your experience has
been like down in the comments section
below
and if you're a fan of the channel if
you guys want to support us buy one of
these super comfy
premium shirts or hoodies or masks down
in that merch shelf
right below this video thank you guys
for watching click that circle above to
subscribe
this been max and i'll see you in the
next video
you